cnr.com the reason why I asked Whoopi
Goldberg claims Trump will put people in
camps they're in camps right now see the
videos right it's Cages under Trump when
it's Obama it's a lovely facility that
happens to be a cage but we won't call
it that exactly and so this is what
they're priming us for we need Mass
deportation yeah we have 10,000 plus
people per day illegally entering the
country AOC says just give them papers
that's not going to that's not going to
solve the problems of the economic
crisis there's more ille coming into the
country on an annual basis and there are
American children being born here right
what they're what they're prepping us
for with these statements from whoopy
Goldberg is that when Donald Trump does
begin the process of I would just say um
typical deportation processes they are
going to produce videos and photos and
they're going to claim he's Hitler and
it's happening and they're going to use
this as propaganda to inight violence
yeah AOC crying at the border wall of
course but because they've done that the
projection
is already happening uh you know
everyone's a fascist except for when
they're functioning like fascists and
you've seen there's no limit to what the
Democrat Party will do to retain power
we've been watching that for the last
few years I mean uh it's scary stuff but
yes they are definitely doing I'm
surprised anyone can actually listen to
the view at this point with a straight
face um who are the people who still do
I honestly I don't know it sort of
interesting I I did when my first book
uh triggered came out uh they had me on
The View and it was the I think it was
like the 5,000th episode
of the view and you know so you know
they're going a little bit I actually
got after a while I actually you know
you fight back and whatever I actually
turned the audience and whoopy was there
mfing uh the audience in in the
commercial break it was sort of amazing
I wish we could get the footage of that
they'll never allow that to get out
there but it was sort of like they're
used to people going on these shows and
they're so desperate to get a little bit
of air time because they're selling
their book or whatever they're
you know product they got or whatever it
may be I was there for a book thing they
didn't even ask me about my book I
figured if they're going to have me on
there uh at least you have the courtesy
of that but it was just an attack
session so then when I sort of went
after whoopy for the you know sort of uh
allowing you know pedophile Roman pansy
and justifying that and joy bear for
blackface and it was I just sort of have
fun because I just like you know what if
this goes really wrong I just Google
like what are the dumbest things ever
said on The View and it's like there was
a long list but there was some pretty
obvious ones and you know they lost
their whole audience but they still have
this sort of they must have some sort of
capture probably you know white Suburban
uh virtue signaling Housewives uh that
they're able to manipulate with their
nonsense cuzz you know they're
correcting themselves all the time but
you know it doesn't matter they they get
the hit out there the media picks it up
it's pushed very effectively through
social media as though it's the gospel
as opposed to nonsense uh so yeah
there's no question that's what they're
doing wasn't it uh Kelly Osborne that
came out and said on The View
specifically that we need all these
immigrants here because they're going to
be cleaning our toilet yeah and and I
quote Donald Trump who's going to scrub
your toilet if they're not here and
everyone else like whoa whoa whoa she's
like no no this is what I mean but that
that's the they don't they don't get it
yeah do you guys think that there's
value to building a wall now
again a big graphine wall Jo bid is
selling the wall off did you know that
we need a nice strong we paid for it we
then sell off the components rather than
taking you know literally you they could
have just completed it uh in the areas
that it matter I mean it was clearly
effective you saw the numbers but they
didn't want to complete it so instead
they paid for the material now they're
selling off the remaining materials so
that you have to buy it again if and
when someone else ever becomes takes
office like there's literally no it's
like Wuhan lab League Theory like of
course it came from the lab like of
course this is intentional from them of
course they want unfettered access to
people who are going to be dependent and
who will ultimately vote Democrat like
they they offer nothing else if you're
not a dependent at this point I get
nervous about the deportation stuff cuz
I like logically it makes sense but
realistically I see the horror of like
people with their cell phones recording
their mother screaming as she's being
pulled out of her living room and then
like every day that kind of stuff on
social media getting played on NBC and
like now imagine this now imagine a
video of a woman crying and screaming as
she's being pulled from a bank vault
carrying a bunch of cash yeah we we we
don't we don't look at that crime being
committed and go oh that poor woman or
the seventh time Deport a guy that raped
women with Reckless abandoned or or you
drove drunk for the fifth time in the
United States and killed someone's son
or smuggling fentanyl across the border
time and time again killing hundreds of
thousands of Americans like you know
there's a video of a man being arrested
in the subway and the cops are roughing
him up you know not not really F hitting
or anything but they're like grabbing
his arm they're pulling it he's
resisting and there's all these comments
on Twitter they're like why is he doing
why are the cops doing this this man he
didn't even do anything he was fighting
cops he he he jumped the turn they said
stop we're going to give you a ticket he
fought with the cops they fought back
and arrested him yes that's how you
enforce laws that's victim crime this
this victimless crime which is part of
what makes deportation challenging like
these Tech victimless they're
technically attacking everyone by
displacing us but real you verify you
make it you you create incentives where
it's harder for them to do maybe they
honestly you probably have a lot of
people self- deporting because if
they're not able to take advantage of
the systems if we're not just abjectly
writing them checks and giving them
phones and telling them hey here's a
phone here's a couple thousand bucks a
month and you know why don't you see us
in 2037 for your court date you know
there are things you can do uh that
don't make it so simple where the
American taxpayer isn't footing the bill
uh in perpetuity
you've got these people hiring human
traffickers actual human traffickers
Smugglers I'm not no not Smugglers
traffickers there are traffickers who
kidnap kids who rape them drag them
across the border and these are the same
people that the other illegal IMS will
go to and pay yeah and so we hear these
these horrifying stories that these
Smugglers let's say the lighter version
of the coyotes they overwhelmingly rape
young girls as they do this it's not a
victimless crime this should not be
allowed to continue now like 40
40% it's not like oh there's you
occasionally it happens and they I know
they went after my father a lot when he
said it but that's the reality I had Tom
Homan the former head of ice on my my
triggered podcast like two weeks ago and
he's talking about I mean the the
stories that these guys could tell if
you could show those videos if you could
show those stories to the American
public uh you'd be building a wall in
about 3 seconds if people understood the
reality of what's actually going on down
there I've done some reporting on the
ground of the refugee crisis that was
spurred on by a lot of the Caravans that
ended up in Tijana and there was a lot
of problems not just when it came to
sanitation not just when it came to a
lot of the diseases and viruses that
were being spread everywhere but
specifically with assaults on women and
children specifically to the point where
they needed an entire other area to
House people and to to put people in
because of the huge amounts of
violations that were happening against
women that were happening against
children and when when you look at a
large number of the people coming
through it's fighting age males uh it's
it's males that of course are in the
peak of their age they're they're coming
here to this country and this is
something that that sadly we don't hear
talked about at all because there's a
big censorship effort trying to deny us
this reality but but a lot of these
people are lied to they're told hey
we're going to give you all this stuff
there's all these opportunities just
come on here everything's going to be
amazing and great for you and for a lot
of them it's not and it's not just
hurting Americans but it's also hurting
them as well as of course a lot of
multinational corporations also take
advantage of them they put them in of
course laborous situations where they
don't have to pay them like they would
an American and they're the ones also
being taken advantage of and from a
humanitarian perspective we have to
understand here I I understand what Ian
is trying to convey but but I think just
stopping the the incentivizing of this
larger program from moving forward just
stop funneling it stop giving it money
that would solve a lot of the problems
go after the corporations hiring these
people go after all these incentives and
then you won't need to force Deport
people people won't leave because people
will naturally will leave Donald Trump
did this yeah like by the way famously
went after several uh meat processing
plants we've talked about it quite a bit
we we we've seen this done it's not you
know that and that's sort of the thing
about my father running right now right
like he did all of the things he said he
was like we we know we can do this you
know them pretending like oh it's
impossible we just can't do it like what
are you talking like we had these
numbers down I mean you know the amount
of you know you talk about the fighting
age males they they they're showing up
with young girls that clearly aren't
their children and they they won't do
the DNA test anymore because it doesn't
matter and they're just like well we
just got to push it through it's too
much to handle I mean we are enabling a
humanitarian crisis of epic proportions
and like you know those those same
Hollywood Elites are just fine with that
maybe listen I guess they're all on the
Epstein tape so they're probably you
know let the attention go elsewhere you
have a 27-year-old male with a
10-year-old girl cross the border and
the Trump Administration said who is
that young girl because we know the KES
are are trafficking and raping young
girls and then the Democrats go oh no
they're separating the daughter from her
father it's like that's some guy with
some kid who is trafficking them and we
know that there's a large amount of rape
going on we need to figure out if these
are victims being trafficked but these
these de these liberals these Democrats
the corpor they don't care would you
guys support military intervention in
Mexico
what does that mean uh dropping bombs uh
targeted assassinations like total just
going yes cartels like I mean in
proportional conflict is the cartel not
an enemy combatant of the United States
are they not a clear and present danger
no we we have to clarify that I I I I
think military just military conflict in
any country can be justified it just
depends on the context if like Mexico
started ritualistically just executing
anybody who was near the border even
American
citizens yes absolutely if cartels were
kidnapping American citizens and then
killing them Mark in reprisal in fact
The Mexican government should be working
with us to stop that that that stuff and
if they don't then we go after them for
the time being I don't know if I I know
enough about the current conflict with
cartels that justifies bombings and
assassinations there's also a lot of
links to the CIA and Intel agencies that
helped a lot of cartels out and work
with the cartels and and are
participating in larger drug trades that
of course are are bringing over the
fentanyl here into the United States as
well as of course they have a history of
bringing in crack of cocaine um and
introducing it to of course the local
populations here here as well so I don't
think that's going to happen Ian mainly
because of there's a conflict of
interest yeah it's on the border which
has its own risk you don't want I mean I
don't know I don't think anyone in
America wants to be fighting on the
border right now and that would could
open that up um so you think that
they're prioritizing economic like
economics over human life the CIA and
whoever's yeah I don't think it's
economics for the American Republic
though I think it's economics for their
own War chest and coffers I mean that
that's probably uh historically far more
accurate than anything that would be
positive for American economics
but man it's it's hard like I I got a
call from a buddy uh this week had some
friends and they were in a hunting camp
in Sonora in Mexico across the border
and cartel's grabbed a couple guys shot
a bunch of the guys they were with and I
guess you know they left some of the
Americans but like I mean they are
actively doing this and by the way and
they're also taking over all of the law
enforcement they more heavily armed and
weaponized than a lot of the Mexican
military I mean this is uh this is a war
zone I I think you know as as Luke is
pointing out with the Intel agencies I
think there's more to it than we realize
100% that these cartels are working with
some level of you know the US government
yeah but I think that's far more of a
threat to the United States than
anything going on in the Ukraine right
now uh I I think it's far more relevant
to our well-being uh than anything going
on there but you know we're fine sending
150 billion to them
without accountability or well there's a
lot of documented cases especially with
operation Fast and Furious especially
with the Obama Administration especially
with even US Special Forces creating
essentially one of the fiercest cartels
in all of Mexico as well so the history
is there and this is the public stuff
that we know about what don't we know
about as of course almost every step of
the way here we see direct government
intervention you could go all the way
back to Iran Contra that was another
major Scandal that the Intel agencies
were part of that they were never held
responsible for the guy in charge of it
got a spot on Fox news for for some
freaking reason and uh when you when we
don't have accountability for these
Intel agencies they're going to continue
to do what they did before so is there a
way to get any kind of accountability
here from them that that's a question
that I think a lot of people have on
their minds especially with how
egregiously they've been overacting
against uh you know your dad listen I I
think you got to try and I think that I
I think now that you know I mean you had
there was some nice things about coming
in as an outsider but I think there were
also some disadvantages right you didn't
who do you actually trust you know The
Plum Book which is you know the
president sort of 4,000 employees you
know they they put into those positions
like I don't know 4,000 people you know
you're going to find 4,000 people that
are actually going to believe in your
movement and this or you know they show
you know they show you three Tweets in
the two weeks in the hiring process oh
yeah no we're pretty for it now he
understands who the snakes are who the
bad people are I think that's what
scares them more I think that's why you
have sort of uh the retaliation going so
much more aggressively at him because he
is the only threat to their hegemony
there um you know you've SE Nikki Haley
it's like you know she was created in a
laboratory uh you know by the neocons
it's like the perfect uh you know
NeverEnding War uh Republican it's like
Liz Cheney um what do you guys think
about
the honestly I I like a lot of what he's
saying you know I I I do I've been
saying that fairly publicly for quite
some time uh I say it on my podcast a
lot um you know I guess and I'd like to
get to know him I don't actually know
him but I I'd like to get to know him um
I I agree with a lot of what he's saying
I on the corollary to that I have a lot
of people you know when I'm just doing
my live stream whatever well but I don't
trust him I was like well I understand
that too because you know I don't know
where he was in 16 18 20 you know 22 uh
I believe he's certainly you know of the
other people other than my father on
that stage he's the smartest of them by
far so I also believe he's smart enough
to tell you what you want to hear if
you're the conservative based voter but
you know I I kind of want to believe you
so maybe it takes some time I think he's
developing I've always bitched we have
no bench you know after Donald Trump we
don't who's the guy you know that before
the primary I mean like I was like two
or three with the Sant I'm like but like
I was a real estate guy until I just
started yelling because no one else is
fighting so I might as well do it we we
don't have that bench of guys that are
going to be rockstars I think there's
some guys coming along you know at JD
Vance there's there's other guys that
are now coming out but like you know I
said it today John fedman is more based
than you know three4 of the United
States Senate like with what he's saying
these days and I'm like meaning on the
Republican side and how does that happen
so we need more of a base we need more
people who are willing to sort of fight
for that America first movement and you
know my father gets that now but you
know I I want to believe I want to
believe that he can get there I I I
don't know enough yet thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net